c'est un point rarement visités de la
campagne craignait une région
caractérisée par la richesse de ses
pâturages et la pauvreté de sa
population
c'est surtout une frontière avec un état
fantoche soutenue par la russie la
république autoproclamée de transnistrie
une frontière autrefois poreuse
alexander klein co se souvient qu'il a
traversées auparavant plusieurs fois par
jour que les gens de sa famille vivaient
de part et d'autre sans problème
mais la guerre avec la russie a tout
compliqué
on ne peut plus passer dit il il ya
maintenant des tranchées et des soldats
armés
lou dû certainement connu résultats
alexander ne peut plus voir sa femme ni
son fils
à l'abri bien qu elle n'a plus de
nouvelles de ses enfants coincés de
l'autre côté de la frontière depuis des
mois alors elle a choisi de ne plus
regarder la télé pour éviter de trop
s'inquiéter
pour bâtir
c'est difficile et je pleure parfois
avoue-t-elle bien sûr que cela fait peur
tous retraités alexander et ses voisins
se soutiennent et s'entraident
mutuellement mais il évite de parler de
la situation qui ne trouve franchement
pas rassurante
[Musique]
victor craignent un coup ne le cache pas
tous ici craignent que la russie décide
d'attaquer l'ukraine par l'ouest depuis
la transnistrie bonnes émotions
nous avons tous peur que la guerre bien
ici dit il bien sûr que nous avons peur
ce qui inquiète surtout alexander c'est
la propagande qui radicalise les
opinions
en transnistrie il parle d'actes
terroristes dans les médias dit il alors
bien sûr s'influencent que les gens
pensent là bas
nostalgique d'une époque où tous manger
à la même table comme des frères
partageant le même morceau de pain les
voisins rêve de paix et d'un retour à la
raison mais ils savent ou pessimiste et
se sentent impuissants
pour les gens ici le conflit qui se
déroule à l'autre bout du pays depuis
2014 a longtemps paru comme quelque
chose de lointain presque abstrait mais
depuis quelque temps la guerre est bien
plus concrète bien plus inquiétante et
dans ce contexte les soldats russes qui
sont à moins d'un kilomètre d'ici en
transnistrie apparaissent beaucoup plus
menaçant
ici jean françois bélanger radio-canada
rebecchi